hello am i happy today i
love watching people on instagram who
spend their whole life
flexing on people to make them jealous
of a
fake lifestyle i love watching those
people
go down and today we're not even
watching someone fall from like grace
we're watching them plummet off a cliff
that they were already
falling off of like it's like when you
fall you know like in the movie when you
fall you hit a rock but then you fall
the rest of
the way down the cliff that's what just
happened to hush puppy
i seem to have fallen down a cliff i'm
still alive but i'm very badly injured
uh 2.5 million followers on instagram he
says he was
a real estate developer snapchat is hush
puppy five aka
the billionaire gucci master and all he
would ever do
is post himself like this you know
wearing clothes
getting having really nice cars people
got very jealous of him they want to
know who is this guy
uh it opened a lot of doors for him and
people thought he was legit
that was until he got charged for oops
doj
nigerian national brought to you guys to
face charges of conspiring to launder
hundreds of millions of dollars from
cyber
crime schemes now remember this already
happened
like a few months ago i mean i didn't
even cover this story because it was
covered by so many outlets it was
everywhere
uh because people were shocked to find
out that this guy's life wasn't real
according to the affidavit and his
complaint abbas maintains social media
accounts that frequently show him in
designer clothes wearing expensive
watches posting in with luxury cars and
charter jets
the fbi's investigation has revealed
that abbas financed this lifestyle uh
through
crime and that he is one of the leaders
of a transnational network
that facilitates computer intrusions
fraudulent schemes including
bec schemes which is like when you like
uh
get people's business emails and have
them wire funds to the wrong account
whatever
that's not what we're talking about
today that's all leading up that's what
i mean he was already
on his way to jail now i don't even know
how much farther can you fall that's the
question well he was just accused of
being in bed
with i i don't even know how to present
this north korean
hackers who were stealing 1.3
billion dollars yeah billion that's
that's a
with a b putting hush puppy up there
with one of the biggest scammers of all
time
perhaps now i want to correct something
the record okay
had said that uh hush puppy was involved
in a 1.6 billion dollar scam
already that's not true okay 1.6 billion
durhams so it wasn't at that level yet
and what i'm trying to impress upon you
is now he's entered a whole new realm
the holy grail of scam and he hit the
beat
i mean grant cardone's jealous of the
billionaire number let me tell you that
right now
everybody on this stream could be a
billionaire
and hush puppy has achieved it he's
connected with this
cyber ring of criminals now this gr
group is known as the lazarus group
they're uh associated with a bunch of
things one of them which being
i think the biggest bank heist in the
world is cyber bank heist which we'll
talk about probably another time
they were responsible for the like sony
hacks you guys remember like the
interview like
north korea all that kind of stuff this
is what these guys look like according
to like a wanted thing by the fbi
anyways how is our hush puppy guy
involved well
they needed to launder the money right
that's the problem of crime is you now
have dirty money which can be traced
so what did they do well they got this
guy this guy alemany
and uh and they also got hush puppy and
they got these two guys to basically uh
launder money sorry it's gallop alamari
apologize about that
here's the dirty details right here with
the respect to north korean
co-conspirators activities a la mari
organized teams of co-conspirators
and one of them of course was raymond
hush puppy
obviously this stacks on top of the fact
that uh they already charged him in a
separate case
alleging that he conspired to launder
hundreds of thousands of dollars or
sorry hundreds of millions
of dollars from bec frauds and other
scams
now why do i tell you guys all about
this right he's gone from
you know probably going to jail to
probably going to jail for longer a
longer period of time if these charges
stick
first of all i selfishly i just like
watching these guys to go down
but on another note look crime doesn't
pay
okay well it does that's the thing it
does until it doesn't
and then when it doesn't all of us get a
laugh at you but we get a laugh at you
when you get arrested you get put in
jail
you can rest assured we will be making
videos mocking you
because you deserve to be mocked you
posed there like you were some
baller dude like we were supposed to
believe you were some boss
you were just working with north korea
to launder a little bit of money you
probably went to an atm you stuck your
hand in there wow big what
real mogul moves my man let's see where
that's gotten you
this guy should be embarrassed but more
importantly
don't drop the soap raymond i've heard
bad things
i just love it at night if i'm bored
i'll just like scroll to hush puppy's
page and just start laughing
oh man i just there is something so
gratifying about it
you flexed on people for so long you
were trying to make them jealous
you were trying to work little deals
trying to launder your reputation into
something legit but in reality all your
money was from scams
and you're getting caught and you
deserve everything that's coming to you
anyway that's basically it i don't know
i just wanted to update you guys on
what's going on maybe you heard this
news story going around just wanted to
cover it thanks for watching and i'll
see you
tomorrow